foxy the pirate would have done anything
to get his hands on the security guard
area yes
not only did he refuse to wear his
costume he was always stopping Freddy
and foxy these other friends from
partying should we do that stop at him
stop partying no more party no Bonnie
always got the door slammed in his face
I guess we should do that too and she
can was always getting stuck just
outside the door oh now I'm stuck Freddy
wasn't even allowed to get close to the
right board why not poor Freddy
no no chica Freddy what are you doing
foxy thought this was very mean whenever
he got the chance they would run as fast
as he could to make it to the left or
sometimes he'd even shoved Bonnie out of
the way just to get there in time you're
supposed to run over here at the same
time but the door was always closed when
foxy arrived in time knock knock no
matter how much he pounded and squealed
he could never get inside to get the
security guide this made foxy very sad
he was the fastest animal in the whole
period no matter how hard he tried he
just couldn't catch that rule break in
the security guy sometimes foxy would
plot to grab the guard on his way to his
office but with his eyepatch and
curtains in the way it was very hard for
foxy to see outside of pirate Cove this
is your prime fairness ban you
everything's 2d I can't see Adam
and I got what I it was very hard for
focuses you see outside and so foxy the
pirate soul resident of the hard er er
pirate hub said quietly at a stage every
day the [ __ ] is going on America waiting
for darkness waiting for the day that he
could finally put that Meany yard back
to his costume I'm totally gonna get
there and we need to order then
something very strange happened one day
when all was quiet in the land of Freddy
fazbear's foxy awoke to rustling of
curtains the first thing he thought was
that somebody was coming to see him
standing alone in pirate camp someone's
coming to see me why stand alone in
pirate Cove this happened a lot to foxy
little kids always thought it was cool
to see a former member of the fazbear's
crew it's always Joel and me they
thought that foxy looked rather cool
with this rusty hook and browning fur
yar foxy did not think that he looked
cool I wish I had a hand everyone always
talks about my look but today there were
no children at the stage to gawk at foxy
no far from it it was the security guy
Fawkes II was shocked
yes I'm shocked he wanted to reach out
with this who can and grab the guard
before he could get away he wanted to
stop him before he could close the door
he wanted wanted more than anything in
the world but as a rule foxy was not
allowed to move until after dark
so foxy was helpless as the man he hated
so set foot into his beloved pirate Cove
oh how dare you you're looking kind of
down foxy my friend he said foxy only
blinked he
was allowed to do that much what did
this this rule break and know about
friends he was a Meany meanies don't
have friends that much foxy was Shura
hey brought you a little something to
cheer you up the security guard said
bring him okay foxy was perfectly still
as the man pulled the black pirate hat
from behind his back I was a black
pirate hat my black pirate hat
it had chalk white drawing over smiling
skull and crossbones in front of it that
kind of foxy used to wear all those
years ago
back before for this then with the
gentleness of an angel the secured God
placed the hat on top of Fox's head
gentleness I'm an angel like an angel
like an angel hey now it's bad looking
sharp foxy it was very difficult for
foxy to deny that the party had felt
really really cold on his head can't
deny it I really liked his hair this is
a good at but he refused to believe that
this man has a sworn enemy the very
reason that he the he and the fazbear's
cruise stocked the halls at night would
ever be kind to him how dare this role
breaking meanie be kind to me I don't
believe it of course that was until the
man pulled out a single screwdriver Oh
still big guy this will this might
tickle what the [ __ ] is his story going
where is he putting the key a
screwdriver there was the squealing
sound of bolts coming loose the noise
that metal makes when rubbed against
other og rubbed against other battles
and then a series of pink sand clings as
foxy felt his teeth fall from his mouth
you can cling cling cling cling the man
whistled foxy did have very sharp teeth
after all that was why he had been
tucked away from the curtains in the
first place I know it's a long shot but
I'm gonna let you give these a try
foxy wasn't sure what he meant by that
but soon after this was said he felt a
number of soft items being pressed into
the slots where his teeth used to be
pizza grill
foxy flex his jaws and try to figure out
what was different but he couldn't
flex what's different see in the morning
foxy the security guard said and with a
friendly pat on the head
the security guy left
foxy alone that night confused and
wondering foxy stayed behind his curtain
all night long
Oh foxy bellowed staggering to and fro
across the stage the children laughed
and squealed as he approached him as
children hey foxy loved the sound of
children welcome welcome
you be trimmed through the one and only
I don't know what you did but you did it
the kids freakin love him what be this
with a cocked head they wobble over to
one of the children nearest the stage
the approaching little girl and what's
your name young less happy can that be a
fine name now little Abbey may I call
you Abbey little Abbey you best be
careful out here in pirate Cove if you
try and steal any of me treasure well he
chomped down on her small fingers with
his brand-new fuzzy stuff teeth he
giggled and squirmed he be walking the
plank soft teeth he's all heart really
all he wants to do is play pirate and so
foxy the pirate soul resident of heart
er er pirate Cove was happy once again
now foxy didn't want to catch the
security guard so much anymore sometimes
though when Freddy Bonnie and chica
weren't trying to get him into his
costume
foxy would run down to the security
guard as fast as he could and then just
before the rule-breaking meanie could
close the door foxy would - inside and
bite his shoulder with his new soft
teeth and give him a big fat spear